nous sommes en septembre 2021 ceci est
la vidéo de rentrer de dtc aujourd'hui
pas de romain pas de blouse blanche pas
de fond vert mais un invité très spécial
le coc id sais pas si vous connaissez
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous savez si vous suivez cette chaîne
je suis vacciné contre le coleader on en
avait parlé ici à l'époque c'était un
sujet maintenant ça l'est beaucoup moins
parce que je rappelle qu on est quand
même beaucoup plus nombreux à être
vaccinés car ne pas l'être ce que vous
savez pas par contre si vous ne suivez
pas sûr twitch et sur les réseaux
sociaux et si vous ne suivez pas fait le
tout ce qu'il faut dans la description
de cette vidéo ce que vous savez pas
donc c'est que j'ai eu le comité
hockey en fait vous le savez sûrement
parce que c'est littéralement le titre
de cette vidéo et ces mêmes sûrement un
peu la raison pour laquelle vous êtes en
train de la regarder en ce moment à son
quand j'en ai parlé sur instagram
l'immense majorité des réactions ça a
confirmé le vaccin donc oui on peut être
vaccinés et avoir le coc vide quand même
et non ça veut pas dire que le vaccin ne
marche pas on va y revenir un petit peu
plus tard parce que c'est important mais
avant ça je vais vous raconter un petit
peu comment ça se passe quand on
malkovich enfin comment ça s'est passé
pour moi c'est une espèce de petit
retour d'expérience sur les trucs
pratico pratiques sur les trucs
administratif et puis quelques petites
réflexions personnelles là dessus et
surtout le reste parce que y'a des trucs
à dire on est fin août et je me sens pas
au top tu fatigues et j'ai le nez qui
coule je me sens enfin c'est pas ouf je
prends ma température et il se trouve
que j'ai 39
donc rendez-vous des lendemains pour un
test pcr et puis je m'enferme chez moi
en attendant les résultats pendant ce
laps de temps j'ai entre eux 39 et 42
ciel donc à vrai dire j'ai pas tellement
envie de sortir un peu plus de vingt
quatre heures après je reçois le
résultat de mon test et il est positif à
partir de ce moment là moi j'ai déjà
plus aucun symptôme mais ça change rien
je dois rester enfermée chez moi sans
sortir ni entrer en contact avec qui que
ce soit pendant dix jours donc je
préviens mes proches et j'attends
le lendemain je reçois un coup de fil de
l'assurance maladie la sécu qui me
propose de l'aide pour musulmans et qui
me demande de faire la liste des
personnes mais qui j'ai été en contact
pendant les 48 heures avant le début de
mes symptômes et puis je reçois un autre
coup de fil d'un centre de suivi qui me
posent là des questions sur mes
symptômes de manière générale et puis à
partir de là bas j'attends patiemment de
pouvoir sortir de chez moi ce qu'il faut
savoir quand on est en isolement parce
qu'on est positif aux commandes c'est
que a priori on peut être contrôlé même
si pour moi ça n'a pas du tout été le
cas par contre au bout de dix jours
personnes puissent vérifier si c'est ok
refait pas de tests pcr par exemple
parce qu'il ya des études qui ont montré
qu' il pouvait être positif encore
pendant plusieurs semaines mais que si
on n'a plus du tout de symptômes depuis
plus de 48 heures c'est qu'on n'est plus
infecté est en tout cas qu'on est plus
contagieux mais n'empêche que si vous
avez encore de la fièvre au bout de dix
jours et que vous sortez quand même pas
ce que vous en avez marre d'être enfermé
by a personne qui va venir de régler du
coup il faut être discipliné et surtout
il faut penser aux autres bon petit
bilan rapide de la prise en charge du
développement côté négatif alors déjà
c'est pas agréable de devoir balancer
les noms des gens avec qui on a été en
contact à l'institut c'est hyper
important il faut le faire on comprend
pourquoi le fait mais c'est vraiment une
sensation désagréable ensuite bouriat
panale d'interlocuteurs j'ai reçu que
deux coups de fil de personnes
différentes mais il ya aussi le suivi en
ligne et j'ai reçu plein de sms pour me
connecter alors que j'avais dit que je
voulais pas en avoir ce serait bien
qu'il y avait un centre référent qui
s'occupe de tout mais bon vaut mieux
trop que pas assez tendue et puis à
quelques bugs informatiques genre j'ai
reçu des documents en double et j'ai été
répertoriés comme quatre contacts alors
que j'étais cas positifs
rien de très grave par contre eu qu un
petit peu plus étonnant quand j'ai
scanné avec tous antico vide le qr code
du résultat de mon test pcr du début sam
hamad au fils mis dans mon carnet de
certificats un certificat de
rétablissement alors que j'étais pas du
tout rétabli parce que j'étais malade et
que j'étais au tout début de isolement
côté positif la réactivité déjà entre le
moment de la prise de rendez vous les
résultats du test pcr et le coup de fil
de la sécu il se passe quelques heures
24 heures à peu près ça m'a vite et puis
les services d'accompagnement qui sont
proposés tout son canal il peut y avoir
un infirmier ou une infirmière qui passe
à domicile pour vérifier que tout va
bien tous les jours on peut se faire
apporter des repas parce qu'on ne peut
pas sortir sur les courses il ya aussi
un numéro d'appel aucun où les une
question quoi que ce soit bon moi j'en
ai pas eu besoin donc je peux pas dire
si ça fonctionne bien mais en tout cas
ça a le mérite d'exister et s'est
proposé systématiquement voilà ça c'est
pour la prise en charge par les services
sanitaires 2 isolement mais quelques
petites réflexions personnelles aussi si
vous le permettez être en isolement
total c'est à dire avant le droit de
voir personne ne pas du tout avoir le
droit de sortir même pas pour faire des
courses et surtout quand on sait que
tous les autres sont dehors sauf nous
c'est un cran au-dessus d'un confinement
c'est pas forcément hyper facile à vivre
ni moralement ni au niveau pratique et
puis être complètement isolé tout seul
chez soi quand on est malade quand on
sait que ça peut se terminer en
réanimation et quand on vous a dit
surtout si vous avez du mal à respirer
appeler le 15 je vous cache pas que
c'est pas ouf non plus
donc mon petit conseil si vous avez des
gens en isolement autour de vous prenez
des nouvelles déjà et puis proposer
votre aide faire des courses déposé un
sac devant la porte quoi que ce soit non
seulement ça rend vraiment service à la
personne qui isolé pour les courses par
exemple en plus ça lui fait du bien ça
la rassure et vous ça vous permet de
vérifier que effectivement tout va bien
pas de problème al'inverse en basant sur
les messages que j'ai le plus
fréquemment reçu je vous propose un
petit florilège des trucs à éviter avec
quatre trucs on pas dire à quelqu'un
qu'ovide mais comment tu as chanté ça
n'est pas tellement que c'est
désagréable comme question c'est juste
que c'est impossible d'y répondre il ya
mille situations dans lesquelles on peut
avoir contaminé et comme le temps
d'incubation c'est à dire le laps de
temps entre la contamination et les
premiers symptômes suivants les gens
savent à deux trois jours à deux
semaines va savoir à quel moment a été
contaminé
c'est un peu comme avec une infection
sexuellement transmissible en fait je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez on en
avait déjà parlé dans une vidéo c'est le
réflexe mais c'est impossible de savoir
qui nous l'a refilé et à qui on l'a
refilé et de toute façon en vrai c'est
pas ça qui est important par contre un
truc est important c'est de prévenir les
gens qu'on a vu pendant qu'on était
content âgées c'est à dire dans les 48
heures avant les premiers symptômes ou
dans les sept jours avant le test
positif si vous n'êtes pas de sitôt
messahel la sécu vous expliquera comment
faire
[ __ ] j'espère que tu mets raffinés
même chose en fait c'est pas parce que
vous avez été testé positif après votre
pote que c'est lui ou que c'est elle qui
vous l'a filé c'est peut-être même vous
qui lui avait refilé ou une autre
personne qui vous l'a refilée à tous les
deux ou à lancer deux personnes
différentes où vous avez fait ça tout
seul on vous des croûtons et dans le
métro par exemple ou rien à voir mais
encore une fois on peut pas savoir et de
toute façon ça changerait donc cherchez
pas à savoir c'est désagréable pour
toulon gros toi t'as pas respecté les
gestes barrière alors déjà tu peux me
disait quelqu'un qui est malade c'est
mieux et en plus on peut respecter les
gestes barrières on axe il ya toujours
des moments où on peut être contaminé
quand même qu'il ya des zones grises les
barrières ça diminue les risques mais
des risques il y en a toujours on va y
revenir après eh ben dis donc ça marche
super bien avec ça à l'appareil en fait
hein c'est pas marrant 2 oui ça marche
bien mais ça ça mérite qu'on s'y attarde
donc on va développer ça tout de suite
après cette transition incroyable
[Musique]
oui parce que comme je voulais dit le
vaccin c'est le truc doute au total le
plus quand tu annonces actuelle comme
une allée chose promise chose due on se
refait un petit pois sur le vaccin donc
oui je suis vacciné j'ai eu deux doses
de finder si vous voulez tout savoir et
oui j'ai chopé le coc vide quand même et
non ça n'a rien d'incroyable n'y a rien
de scandaleux ni rien de drôle et déjà
première chose c'est dit depuis le début
mais c'est bien de le rappeler
manifestement le vaccin ça protège avant
tout contre les formes graves
perso j'ai eu de la fièvre et le nez qui
coule pendant 24 heures c'est moins
violent qu'un séjour en réa mais ça on
va y revenir après deuxième chose oui le
vaccin il protège aussi contre la
transmission du virus mais pas à 100% et
surtout c'est difficile d'avoir des
chiffres précis parce que parce que
troisième chose les variants change la
donne notamment le variant delta qui est
beaucoup plus contagieux donc forcément
ça modifie les pourcentages d'efficacité
qui ont été calculés pendant les tests
sur une version du virus qui était
beaucoup moins contagieuse à l'époque et
puis quatrième et dernière chose il ya
de plus en plus de gens qui sont
vaccinées donc statistiquement il ya de
plus en plus de gens vaccinés qui choque
le bolide mais ça veut pas dire que le
vaccin est plus efficace ça c'est des
maths les probabilités c'est moins ma
partie mais je vous renvoie vers une
vidéo de saïan son rôle je vous mets le
lien dans la description cet été plus de
80% des cas positif c'était des
personnes non vaccinées et des personnes
entièrement axim est positive quand même
c'était à peu près 6 % et pour les
hospitalisations c'est les mêmes
chiffres ça a été dit dans la vidéo dont
je vous parlais prolonge tourner cette
vidéo il ya soixante-sept pour cent de
l'ensemble de la population française
qui est vacciné est à peu près 80% des
gens qui peuvent être vaccinés c'est à
dire les plus de 12 ans qui le sont
effectivement ça c est pas mal accéléré
avant l'été on comprend bien que il y
avait 100 % de la population qui était
vacciné il y aurait 100 % des nouveaux
4go vides et des hospitalisations qui
seraient des gens vaccinés alors ça
n'arrivera pas les 100 % mais les
chiffres dit montre quand même que les
personnes non vaccinées ont plus de
risque d'être malade et de développer
des formes graves que les personnes
vaccinées pour comprendre pourquoi on va
faire un petit rappel sur comment ça
marche tout simple en utilisant une
allégorie derrière nous sommes en guerre
non toujours pas on va considérer
qu'être contaminé c'est une agression on
est là on se balade on s'y attend pas
bîmes ça me tombe dessus et évidemment
on va chercher à se défendre pour se
défendre on a nos systèmes immunitaires
mais notre système immunitaire il sait
pas forcément comment faire il connaît
pas l'agresseur donc bon en fonction de
sa force il fait ce qu'il peut mais ils
galèrent plus ou moins parce que il est
pris au dépourvu le vaccin c'est un
cours de self défense pour notre système
immunitaire
ça lui apprendra à reconnaître le virus
donc il peut s'entraîner à le combattre
comme ça il sait quoi faire le jour où
et lui tombe dessus pour de vrai alors
attention ça reste un combat notre
système immunitaire il va pas forcément
éclaté le virus complètement mais il va
quand même vachement plus le défoncer
que s'il n'était pas du tout entrer
maintenant métaphore dans la métaphore
imaginer que ce combat il a lieu dans un
jeu vidéo vous voyez la barre de vie et
bah c'est exactement comme ça que ça
marche soit le virus fait diminuer votre
barre de vie et vous tombez malade soit
c'est vous qui fait diminuer la barre de
vie du peuple
et plus votre système immunitaire est
fort plus il est entraîné plus la barre
de vie du virus diminue et bien dans la
réalité cette barre de vie du virus
c'est la charge virale c'est à dire la
quantité de virus qu'on a dans notre
organisme quand on est contaminé et
cette charge général toutes les études
tendent à démontrer qu'elles jouent un
rôle important dans l'évolution vers les
formes graves de la maladie en gros plus
à charge virale est grande plus on a de
risques de développer une forme grave et
plus elle est basse plus on a de chance
soit deux pas du tout développer la
maladie soit de faire une forme atténuée
il pour la contagiosité c'est pareil les
dernières études menées sur la question
confirment l'hypothèse initiale selon
laquelle moins on a de virus en août
donc plus la charge virale et basse - on
est content a dû donc le vaccin en
entraînant date système immunitaire il
lui permet de faire baisser beaucoup
plus la barre de vie du virus donc de
gagner qu'on a pour résumer en gros le
vaccin voilà ce qui peut faire quand on
est en contact avec le virus le vaccin
il peut diminuer la charge gras il
diminue la quantité de virus on a en
août donc il diminue le risque quand on
maladie diminue le risque qu'on enfile
autour de nous et surtout il diminue le
risque coface une forme grave donc au
mieux comme aux reflets ou pire qu'on
meurt et du coup il peut aussi éviter
qu'on surcharge les hôpitaux au point
qu'on soit obligé de s'enfermer et
encore pendant des semaines ou des mois
le temps que ça se calme et qu'on puisse
soigner les gens correctement sa vie
peut le faire par contre ce qui peut pas
faire c'est faire disparaître tous les
risques complètement sa vie peut pas et
il peut pas non plus nous empêcher
d'être en contact avec le virus parce
que le virus circule donc pour ça faut
trouver d'autres trucs d'autres trucs
genre les gestes barrière je sais pas si
vous avez entendu parler c'est tout
nouveau en fait c'est une erreur de
penser qu'il ya une solution qui va tout
régler et qui va permettre d'arrêter la
pandémie et c'est une erreur de penser
aussi que les mesures sanitaires soit
elle fonctionne à 100% soit ça veut dire
qu'elle marche pas du tout c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche on y arrive en
faisant diminuer au maximum tous les
risques de contamination ça ce n'est pas
par un truc bien que ça se fait en
agissant sur les différentes sources de
risques avec différents moyens mais
soyons clairs il n'y a pas de risque
zéro de contamination est donc de
maladie ce qui s'en approche le plus
c'est un confinement généralisée c'est à
dire personne sort de chez soi par
contre pour éviter d'en arriver encore
là on peut additionner les autres moyens
les gestes barrières les masques
isolement des personnes infectées le
vaccin et ces délits d pour mémoire
c'est ne pas saturer les hôpitaux et en
particulier les services de réanimation
avec les formes graves parce que ça
c'est un problème pour tout le monde
pour les malades et pour leurs proches
et bien évidemment pour le personnel
hospitalier qui est sur les rotules
depuis un an et demi qui en nombre
limité et qui du coup peuvent pas
soigner les gens de façon efficace et
pour tout le monde en fait parce que si
nous demain on a besoin d'être
hospitalisés en réanimation et qui a pas
de place il n'y a pas de place donc on
n'est pas hospitalisée en réanimation ça
vaut pour les gens qui feraient une
forme grave du code vide mais ça vaut
aussi pour les gens qui auraient un
problème cardiaque qui ferait un avc
corps et un accident de la route etc
s'il n'ya pas de place en riant il n'y a
pas de plateau rien et ça touche la
clairière parce que vu que tous les
services sont surchargés depuis un an et
demi bah il ya plein de rendez vous il
ya plein d'opérations qui sont reportés
reporter reporter et ça c'est pas vous
non plus donc vous voyez tout ce qui
peut limiter le nombre de cas est le nom
de forme grave c'est crucial alors je
sais que tout le monde en a marre mais
tant que c'est pas fini ou tant que
c'est pas stabilisée parce qu'on est de
moins en moins sûr que ça va vraiment
finir complètement hors à jour on n'a
pas trop le choix et c'est pas en
faisant semblant que le virus n'existe
plus qui va arrêter et d'exister suis
même exactement le contraire donc quoi
et un petit mot pour les gens qui
seraient tentés de tout arrêter de tout
refuser en bloc et de rentrer en
résistance historiquement les
résistances et pas des gens qui sacrifie
l'intérêt général pour leur petit
intérêt personnel
là encore c'est même exactement le
contraire voilà dtc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout pour que
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]